the united states has carried out a
drone strike against the militant group
responsible for the attack on kabul
airport that left more than 100 people
dead u.s central command claims that the
target a member of the group known as
isk was killed the strike took place in
afghanistan's nangaha province the u.s
said it was not aware of any civilian
casualties the pentagon is now bracing
for retaliatory attacks and has warned
that the coming days could be the most
dangerous in its withdrawal operation
which is due to end on tuesday
let's cross straight now to journalists
france marty and kabul for the latest on
the situation france what more can you
tell us about that overnight u.s drone
strike on the suspected is is terrorists
details are still unclear the drone
strike apparently hit the house in
police district 7 in jalalabad
i have talked to a source
who has links to to militants in in
jalalabad
but
there have been no clear clear details
emerging
how many people died or who was exactly
in the house um i will still follow this
up but at the moment um no one knows
exactly apparently okay friends no we're
going to talk about the situation at
kabul airport in just a moment so stay
with us while we have a look at this
report about the many people who are
still desperate to leave afghanistan
a long list of those injured at kabul
airport
many afghans have come to this hospital
to look for their loved ones
who didn't come home after the suicide
bombing
we searched all over went to every
hospital
and finally we found his name on the
list here
he's 19 and wants to go to the us the
evacuation flights continue at kabul
airport for now but the american
soldiers let only a few people through
their checkpoint
and the taliban closed the streets
around the airfield
before the attack these roads were
packed
a day later those same thoroughfares are
deserted
the refugees are now thronging downtown
kabul this family wants to flee to
germany even though its evacuation
flights have ceased one of them has a
german visa
we have been here for a week we sold
everything they didn't let us into the
airport no one checked our papers people
without visas are to blame for the chaos
more and more people are also trying to
cross afghanistan's border with pakistan
the pakistanis are only letting people
with visas through everyone else is
being turned away
we have seen in recent weeks a great
deal of population movement when the
conflict and the insecurity came to
people's doors so we have around half a
million people who've been forced to
flee their homes often with nothing in
their hands
the un wants pakistan to let afghans
without visas cross the border it's also
planning to deliver food from these
crossings as afghanistan faces a
humanitarian crisis
okay back to france marty in kabul
france the u.s is warning of more
terrorist attacks in the coming days or
even hours what does that mean for the
crowds waiting outside kabul airport
warnings have been issued since a few
days already a few days before the
attacks
they have become more severe
but there are no details shared on what
exactly
might happen
u.s officials has talked about possible
rocket attacks or attack with a car bomb
but details are unclear in general uh
the situation is not much different than
than than before
that there was a threat
of
attack by the self-declared islamic
state
was already before the case it is also
now so it can't be ruled out but they uh
do something
on the other hand um if they would have
had immediate capability it would be
more likely that they would have stage
like two three attacks in short
concessions so
it's really hard to say
there is a threat but it might not be as
big as as some assume
france can you tell us who is in control
of the airport now the taliban said
they'd taken over parts of the area the
u.s military says that's not true what
are you hearing
yeah it is complex so yesterday night
the taliban have like published
photos of their so-called special forces
going into the airport taking over
certain positions
this has apparently happened but as far
as i can tell this is like part of
the soon to to come hand over um so the
taliban haven't like
taken control of the whole airport just
off certain parts inside the airport
where they haven't been before
um and this seems to have been done in
coordination with the americans
okay france marty in kabul thanks so
much for your reporting
and for more on the group known as
islamic state khorasan or isk i'm joined
now by jan senpier
a counter-terrorism policy consultant
here in germany and thanks so much for
your time can you tell us how big of a
threat this group poses
well right now because of the
circumstances in kabul the the chaos the
opportunity for targets uh and and also
above all else the um the difficulties
in securing an area this group does
represent a high level of threat where
we're understanding better now how the
advantage to pull off the attack on
thursday and it really shows that they
they use the build vulnerabilities on
site uh to to carry out their attack and
the chaos just keeps growing therefore
they're still in a position to to be
extremely threatening
it doesn't you don't need high logistics
you know this is really a small scale
attack in terms of preparation
nonetheless it has big consequences and
therefore the logistics required uh
for such an attack
create the conditions where this group
can still be a highly threatening
describe to us what drives isk what are
they fighting for
well they're fighting for what they
consider to be the real islam the real
sharia and this really differentiates
them from from the taliban they consider
the taliban to be a group that moved
away from the real principles and values
of islam and for them that view is not
rigorous enough and this is what they're
pushing for
what needs to be understood with this
group is that it does remain fairly
small this is not a it can't be in terms
of size or importance be compared to
what we saw in the middle east whether
in syria or iraq but it's still a group
that has a growing number of followers
it has a
substantial regional network that allows
it to to grow and sustain itself but
it's a group that really uh
tries to establish a new state
according to its terms that are very
different from what we understand to be
a more radical view of islam
the u.s went to war in afghanistan after
the 9 11 attacks to route out
kaida and destroy the taliban do you see
afghanistan once again becoming a home
for international terror groups
i i not that afghanistan per se i think
the the interpretation or the perception
of afghanistan being this hub for for
terrorism is really difficult because
it's not just afghanistan's the region
as a whole we know pakistan for years
was was a hub for this um you know we
know parts of iran parts of you know the
other central asian states are conducive
for for this so it's not just
afghanistan obviously in a circumstance
where a
power whether it's the taliban or an
official government don't have full
control over territory that leaves gaps
for
groups whether uh
harmful or for something or something
else to grow and to become a threat i
think right now what we're focusing on
and what we're seeing is that it'll be
more of a regional threat and then it
could perhaps because of the success of
these groups
lead to something bigger but in the
short term it's really more of a
regional problem
jan st pierre thank you so much for your
insights
now after a deployment lasting almost
two decades and costing billions of
euros german troops have now left
afghanistan as the troops return home
around 4 000 afghans who were also
brought to germany are now facing the
challenge of adapting to a new life the
government admits though that more than
twice that number may have been left
behind
after almost 20 years in afghanistan the
soldiers have come home
germany's mission in the country was the
toughest and longest the bundesmere has
faced
the last part of it the evacuation from
kabul was the most dangerous as the
troops arrived at a military base near
hanover the defense minister did not shy
away from the tragedy on the ground
my first thoughts on this evening are
directed at the victims of yesterday's
appalling terrorist attack both the
civilian victims and of course
especially our american comrades with
whom we carried out this operation side
by side
i'm also thinking of those who are left
behind in kabul
we have said we will do everything we
can to get them out of kabul and out of
afghanistan in the coming weeks
german forces airlifted more than 4 000
afghans from kabul during their 11 day
rescue operation the final transport to
land in tashkent left the afghan capital
amid dramatic scenes using an emergency
takeoff procedure after terrorists
attacked at the airport
afghans reunited with family members at
frankfurt airport are survivors of a
dangerous escape
we were able to leave kabul and catch
the last flight out the situation got
worse and worse because of the crowds of
people there was a mass panic and
shootings and it was barely possible to
get into the airport
the u.s air base at ramstein in germany
is hosting those trying to get to
america more than 18 000 have been
processed here in recent days
many of those have already boarded
flights across the atlantic
while others tell of the desperate
journey to reach this point and of their
plans for a new life
complete my
study
which i can't able to study in kabul in
afghanistan
in war situation the situation was very
bad and i hope that complete
my study
in united states
meanwhile those afghans who will remain
in germany are finding their way around
their new home
they are the luckier ones according to
the government in berlin at least 10 000
afghans entitled to come may still be in
the country